I don't need Matsui anymore, don't I have to worry about it?
[Music]
My name is in a certain area of the Far East, and I know how to live.
That's the origin of my name. Yes,
my creator said that I was a perfect human being without suffering.
I have no pain, so I don't have any suffering.
The need is about 80% of the blood vessels.
Next, let's connect the nerves.
Why do I have one company? It
's my job to do my best for the patient.
People who don't suffer from it are likely to suffer like you.  I don't have a face
[Music]
This is
a sale of my teacher 9 Triff, but it seems that the pain is a sign of
being alive. Mr. Funai is alive.
But it ’s the job of a company that relieves everything. I
ca n’t remove everything. It ’s just relieving.
There ’s
someone like you.
It ’s much better
, it ’s gray, and let ’s take it to the left foot
.